what's going on in the United States
right now I know you have a point of yes
what's going on the United States right
now is very scary I think I know a lot
of people from my travels all around the
world who are very concerned about
what's happening and certainly Americans
are concerned about what's happening and
but they voted this guy well some people
did he actually lost by two and a half
million votes the popular vote the
popular vote but because of the
breakdown they rely for college he will
be the the president just as George Bush
became the president even though Al Gore
and the board yeah so and we'll have to
see from there but I'm very concerned
about it what do you expect are you
really concerned what do you expect what
we expect and we Mexicans I mean well I
certainly hope you don't pay for this
stupid wall of his I think you needs to
say hell no we're not gonna hell no and
you know it's a repugnant idea you know
I've I've talked about on my blog I know
the importance of immigration to the
United States the United States is a
country built on immigration the only
people who really have any moral right
to say get rid of all these immigrants
are the the Indians ten Native Americans
legitimate grievance good that's it
that's about it everybody else who came
in was an immigrant and then later
someone else came in and they were all
upset about oh that this new group is
and we were good our group now I am a
self I'm a typical American mongrel I
mean I'm just I have Irish and Irish
French and English on my mother's side
on my father's side I have Welsh German
and Italian you know Martin itself oneís
goes back two generations it was
originally a master Cola from Italy and
got changed in Ellis Island I may get
more American I'm a thorough very
mongrel and I believe in immigrants
immigrants that made the United States
great and every immigrant wave that has
come in has faced discrimination and
hostility but I believe in the words
that they're written on the Statue of
Liberty
you know I lift my lamp beside the
Golden Door you know give me your tired
your poor your huddled masses yearning
to be free and the kind of hostility
that Trump has given voice to this
anti-immigrant hostility is the
antithesis of that you know this guy has
no right to even visit the Statue of
Liberty because he represents something
very very different and of course the
two immigrant groups now who are bearing
the brunt of this anti-immigrant fever
are Mexicans and Hispanics in general
and also there's a huge controversy of
the Syrian refugees and how many Syrian
refugees are we going to take and you
know they're mostly women and children
you know some men who were trying to get
away from a horrible war they're there
they're not Isis they're fleeing Isis
Isis Isis and and they're escaping from
the the Syrians and the Russians
together have destroyed their homes
bombed their cities to rubble
some of our on death lists you know
they're they wanna go someplace safe to
live and that's the civilized world I
think has an obligation to find the
place for them including the United
States but
what should Americans do if he starts I
mean I think there are many like control
the United States have what four
Americans have to do if he doesn't
actually seem to understand how the
government works I mean he's sometimes
he sounds like he's gonna run the
presidency like he ran a corporation
where he gives an order and everybody
does it
of course he doesn't own the United
States even when he's sworn in this
president there are checks and balances
but the Republicans do control both
houses of Congress now Senate is very
narrow the Senate is is going to be like
51 to 49 or what the court is 4 to 4
with a vacancy where the vacancy so you
know he has to some things you can do by
executive order other things he'll have
to propose a bill and it'll have to be
passed by both houses of Congress and
then there will be lawsuits and it'll go
through the courts it'll go through so I
don't know it it all depends on how much
he does what he tries to do how much
support it has but I think there are
years of struggle I had at least four
yes there will be another election for
Congress in two years of course all the
members of the House of Representatives
are free election plus twenty odd
senators so we will we will see who gets
elected then and that could changed the
balance but how much it will change it
will depend on where we are in two years
where is the economy where as what's
happened in foreign affairs what's
happened in the Middle East with Isis
are things worse are things better I
don't I don't know that obviously
effects on how things work
you know I do think it behooves writers
in particular to use the skill that
they've been given and to write and to
speak out and to I've been doing that in
your blog we're going to do it and
you're going to be active and yeah well
I'm not gonna stop writing my novels in
order to you know run for Senate or
anything like that but I'm certainly
going to continue to make my opinion
known I mean I hope that does some good
there are days I don't know with anybody
listens anymore you know it just seems
locked in to their own view and you know
you you express an opinion and you get
the people agree with you saying yay
good for you right on you tell them and
you get the people who don't agree with
you saying how dare you say that you're
stupid I hate you so it's okay to change
minds with with facts and rationality
and argument anymore I don't know but
I'd you have to make the effort yeah you
have to make the effort